la gare de Lyon comment la trouvez-vous
le Gard de Lyon c'est un peu c'est un
peu populaire en tout de même nous
aimerions bien avoir une garde de luxe
qui ne ressemble pas à une gare de
banlieue
[Musique]
la vie ensemble de Jacques frémontier
la gare du rêve
réalisation
Marceau ginesty
je me sens pris d'une espèce de peur
religieuse
devant ce chemin que crève la locomotive
et au cours ma vie
et moi le fier moi le brave je me sens
pas lire et je crois que je vais pleurer
voilà dans Paris
c'est ainsi que j'y entre
[Musique]
on demande monsieur Eugène de raspigna
au contrôle
monsieur Eugène de Rastignac a demandé
au contrôle Eugène de Rastignac
avait un visage tout méridional
le thym blanc des cheveux noirs
il portait une vieille redingote un
mauvais gilet
un pantalon à l'avenant et des bottes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il lança sur cette ruche bourdonnante un
regard qui semblait par avance en pompe
et le miel et dit ces mots grandios
l'air de Paris le grisait il croyait
entendre dans le roulement des voitures
les voix de macbf qui lui criait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le train
moi
j'aime l'amour en vacances
sur la voie a le train rapide 183 Train
Bleu départ 20h45 en wagon libre
première et seront là avec
gentiment les choses sans se presser au
rythme du train qui démarre
s'aventurer puis enfin s'abandonner
quand le train siffle dans le soir
pardon madame où allez-vous je m'en vais
passer deux mois dans ma propriété du
Cap d'Antibes pourquoi ne prenez-vous
pas l'avion parce que j'en ai trop peur
mais le train c'est tellement plus
confortable et on est si bien servi
c'est bien servi on est aussi bien servi
qu'autrefois autrefois mais je n'ai pas
connu les trains d'autrefois mais le
train bleu ça n'a pas beaucoup changé
depuis laver l'époque
[Musique]
la gare de Lyon comme on l'a trouvé
c'est un peu populaire en tout de même
nous aimerions bien avoir une garde de
luxe qui ne ressemble pas à une gare de
banlieue
[Musique]
le train
arrivées à 7h10 est annoncé vois 5 avec
un retard probable de 20 minutes
nous vous prions de nous en excuser
[Applaudissements]
madame monsieur est-ce que je peux vous
poser une question s'il vous plaît
vous venez tous les matins par train de
banlieue à la gare de Lyon
tous les matins
parce qu'on est toujours serré puis
d'abord il y a pas cette place moi
j'aimerais on avait déjà essayé de
demander de mettre des trains tous les 8
minutes à peu près au lieu de tous les
quarts d'heure mais évidemment on n'a
jamais rien eu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le conseil d'administration de la SNCF
prendra toute mesure de nature à réduire
les charges de la société nationale
notamment par la transformation de ces
modes d'exploitation ou la limitation
voir la suppression de certaines de ses
services lorsque ces mesures sont
justifiées par son intérêt commercial
Avenant du 27 janvier 1971 à la
convention du 31 août 1938 est-ce qu'il
vous arrive monsieur de prendre un train
le soir pour venir au spectacle à Paris
non très rarement parce que vous savez
le train le dernier train c'était à 1h
du matin alors on risque de se faire
coincer dormir à la gare à la gare quoi
je vous ai déjà arrivé oui deux trois
fois
le prochain train qui est vers 4h du
matin
qu'est-ce que vous faites comme travail
ben je travaille je suis électricien
vous travaillez sur des chantiers oui
chantier je travaille un peu partout
quoi c'est le bâtiment
et vous madame qu'est-ce que vous faites
genre d'entreprise
vous êtes professionnel ou
non
[Musique]
pas dans ton lit
entre Nice
quand le train roule dans la nuit
l'amour enfin sur la voie a le train
rapide 183 un bleu départ 20h45 en
vacances
nous sommes environ une trentaine à
l'effectif actuellement
suffisant pour assurer le service des
clients
c'est suffisant à certains moments mais
à d'autres moments c'est nettement
insuffisant c'est à dire quand il y a
beaucoup de travail nous sommes trop peu
nombreux pour assurer un service correct
que vous appartenez à SNCF vous les
porteurs non nous faisons partie d'une
société privée qui travaille pour la
SNCF est-ce que ces sociétés vers
certaines sommes à la SNCF pour obtenir
ce droit de concession du service de
portage il y a eu un temps où les
sociétés de portage
donnaient un certain nombre d'heures
gratuites à la SNCF en échange de la
concession actuellement c'est fini il
n'y a plus assez de travail
pour que les sociétés de portage
puissent se permettre de
payer à la SNCF le droit de travailler
est-ce que c'est un bon système
n'importe comment ce système de
concession
disons que pour la SNCF ça lui évite
évidemment de
d'envoyer des d'avoir un certain nombre
de d'employés
qui profiteront des avantages de la SNCF
c'est à dire retraite à 55 ans
son salaire intégral en cas de maladie
etc donc la carte de circulation et
autres avantages vous ne les avez pas
non absolument pas puisque nous faisons
partie d'une société privée
est-ce que vous souhaiteriez faire
partie de la SNCF
oui évidemment
quand aux opérations de nettoyage elles
sont du domaine de l'industrie privée
qui utilisent pour cela il met d'oeuvre
non qualifiée dont le prix de revient
est toujours inférieur à celui de nos
personnels rapports de Monsieur Guibert
directeur général 1968 page 12
c'est la SNCF qui vous emploie c'est pas
la SNCF tout à fait la Saint-Cyr
c'est
une entreprise privée
[Musique]
vous êtes de quelle nationalité monsieur
est-ce que votre entreprise utilise
beaucoup de travailleurs étrangers oui
travailler à quelle heure on commence à
8h jusqu'à 5h
par semaine on fait 45 46 heures
par mois
cette fin de là les dames qui nettoient
les wagons à l'intérieur elles sont
algériennes aussi
un chef de garde dans une gare comme la
gare de Lyon qu'est-ce que c'est un
grand patron c'est un chef d'entreprise
c'est le maître du temps je pense que
vous faites allusion ma tour du temps
parce que nous sommes à côté des cadrans
de la Tour de l'Horloge ça correspondent
du reste à un souci important pour un
chef de guerre qui est la régularité de
la circulation
parcours à la gare de Lyon on a
l'impression d'y rencontrer de plus en
plus d'entreprises qui ne sont pas la
SNCF d'entreprise privée est-ce que
c'est vrai oui nous employons beaucoup
d'entreprises privées dans la maison
des entreprises de manutention pour les
travaux de manutention des changements
des colis aménagement des oreillers et
des couvertures dans les couchettes
nous avons des entreprises qui
travaillent à l'intérieur de la gare
comme les PTT qui assurent beaucoup de
transport par la voie ferrée et nous
avons
les entreprises pour les services
voyageurs comme les wagons en lits et
bien certains que si vous allez du côté
marchandise vous allez trouver beaucoup
d'entreprises qui sont des entreprises
de groupage qui travaillent à
l'intérieur de nos emprises nous leur
avons ce sont nos locataire et nous
assurons pour elle leur transport de
marchandises
[Musique]
quel est l'intérêt de la SNCF de faire
travailler des entreprises privées sur
son propre territoire
l'intérêt c'est d'avoir une certaine
souplesse pour l'utilisation du
personnel et de toute façon il y a des
choses qui ne que nous ne pourrions pas
assurer donc on a besoin de d'une aide
de ces entreprises
dans l'utilisation des personnel sur
place d'utilisation du personnel car les
règles de l'utilisation de personnels
relativement stricte alors que les
entreprises ont tout de même un peu plus
de libéralité
par exemple par exemple au point de vue
durée du travail au point de vue
aménagement des repos et puis les
entreprises sont faciles plus facilement
en face à des périodes de pointe que la
SNCF à ce qui concerne les fournitures
personnelles
qu'est-ce que c'est votre métier c'est
comme chef d'équipe ici
c'est une entreprise ici pourquoi est-ce
que c'est une entreprise c'est pas moi
parce que quand je suis embauché je
trouvais l'entreprise alors je travaille
avec l'entreprise
[Musique]
qu'on arrive à mal comprendre c'est que
dans une perspective où l'on essaie
d'accroître la rentabilité de
l'entreprise publique on concept des
activités rentables à des entreprises
privées
ce sont des prestataires de service en
leur demande simplement des fournitures
de personnel
mais ce ne sont pas eux qui
interviennent en ce qui concerne les
problèmes commerciaux ce ne sont pas eux
ça c'est toujours le cheminot qui reçoit
les colis qu'il les enregistre qui fait
payer le client il n'y a pas de ce n'est
pas l'entreprise qui fait ce travail là
l'entreprise fait uniquement une
prestation de service pour assurer la
manutention des colis la SNCF a sa
propre filiale de messagerie et
cependant elle fait appel au service de
groupeur qui assure également des
services de messagerie où est son
intérêt en la matière le Sernam est en
concurrence avec les groupeurs qui qui
assurent les transports par voie ferrée
effectivement Sernam est en concurrence
avec nos clients de ensuite des
chantiers de Bercy qui sont installés
sur notre terrain et qui a sur leur
transport par voie ferrée c'est
exactement le même problème que les
transports de voyageurs et Transports de
voyageurs par route vous avez une
concurrence qui existe et existe là pour
le transport des colis regrouper il
paraissent par essence même un
transporteur de colis comme le serment
messieurs vous êtes des chefs de service
d'une entreprise de groupage un groupeur
à quoi ça sert qu'est-ce que c'est un
gros peur est un prestataire de service
qui consiste à rassembler de la
marchandise en provenance de différents
expéditeurs et destinés à même lieu
bon vous êtes une entreprise privée il y
a un service public qui est SNCF on peut
se demander à la limite pourquoi les
SNCF ne fait pas ce travail elle-même
Tintin la SNCF faisait ce travail
elle-même et depuis quelques années la
confier à une de ses filiales qui
s'appelle la Sernam
pourquoi
de ce concurrencer elle-même
c'est-à-dire de donner du travail à des
concurrents du surnomme
c'est surtout pouvoir public qu'il faut
demander ça
il ne fera tout
je crois enfin
c'est assez difficile de vous répondre
sur ce point va vous ignorez pas que la
SNCF a eu quelques difficultés c'est
certainement pour essayer de surmonter
cette difficulté qu'ils ont créé ce
nouveau service
c'est un service bénéficiaire
le surname
si nous en croyons la presse oui
et votre propre entreprise est-elle
bénéficiaire
nous travaillons pour la lettre
vous travaillez nous travaillons pour la
lettre bénéficiaire bien dites-vous oui
vous êtes ici sur un territoire SNCF ce
gars appartient à la SNCF est-ce que
vous payez une redevance à la SNCF
se forment d'un tonnage que nous devons
lui fournir
et si vous ne fournissez pas cette
tenace
un loyer
vous avez un embranchement privé ici
est-ce que c'est un manchon privé
implique que vous ayez des tarifs
préférentiels de la part d'un SNCF la
SNCF a toujours fait les tarifs
préférentiels pour les groupes
c'est-à-dire que vous bénéficiez d'un
double avantage qui est d'une part la
concession de d'une gare et d'autre part
des tarifs préférentiels
particuliers pour embranchement
particulier
tarif particulier pour wagon complet
tarif particulier pour wagon particulier
tarif particulier pour très complet
[Applaudissements]
monsieur Sanchez est-ce que votre
personnel bénéficie des mêmes avantages
que le personnel de la SNCF
les mêmes avantages que le personnel de
la SNCF je ne peux pas vous répondre car
je ne sais pas de quels avantages il
bénéficient mais chez nous nous avons
beaucoup d'avantages sociaux
parmi les avantages majeurs il y a bien
évidemment la stabilité de l'emploi il y
a aussi un âge de la retraite qui est
plus précoce que pour l'ensemble des
salariés français
alors pour l'âge de la retraite nous
avons la retraite normale comme tous les
salariés et des entreprises privées bien
sûr
quant à la stabilité de l'emploi il n'y
a aucun problème nous sommes comme vous
l'a dit Monsieur Rochette une entreprise
prospère et de ce fait il n'y a pas de
problème de ce côté-là est-ce que vous
utilisez beaucoup d'immigrés oui oui
pourcentage qui est relativement élevé
ce qui est une différence avec la SNCF
la SNCF est une société nationalisée
nous sommes une société privée et de ce
fait nous pouvons faire appel à tout le
personnel
vous nous avez répété après monsieur
Rochette que votre entreprise était
prospère
la SNCF elle ne l'est pas ou ne l'a pas
toujours été pourquoi dans ces
conditions concept-elles des services
qui sont bénéficiaires
d'une question qui est très difficile à
répondre je peux vous répondre de ce qui
est notre problème je ne peux pas
répondre de problème de la SNCF
[Musique]
je ne viens pas vous acheter un billet
je voudrais vous poser deux trois
questions oui entrez faites le tour
merci
3 ans
et quel âge avez-vous 21 ans comment
est-ce qu'on devient
tout simplement j'ai répondu à une
annonce inscrit sur le journal et on
montre convoqué pour venir ici je me
suis retrouvé au guichet huit jours
après avoir reçu la convocation
vous avez reçu une formation
professionnelle non aucune
aucune on m'a mis au guichet un peu à
l'étude à observer les collègues et puis
après on m'a mis tout seul il y a des
machines la manipuler cette automatique
est-ce que ce sera pas facilement la
manipulation de ces machines assez
facilement oui on n'a pas quand même
rapidement même
est-ce que vous arrive de commettre des
erreurs ah oui beaucoup et surtout des
erreurs d'argent vendant aux clients et
tes erreurs là c'est nous qui les
remboursons pas à la fin du trimestre
ça peut atteindre des sommes de quelle
l'importance 100 francs voire 200 francs
même ça arrive certains collègues
erreurs de 200 francs sortir à la fin du
trimestre sur une paye qui n'est pas
tellement énorme ça fait beaucoup
quel est telle votre paye de l'ordre de
1100 francs
1100 francs et prime de 150 francs 150
francs 160 francs de prix par mois
quels sont vos horaires
nous allons
irréguliers on travaille les nuits
également comme aujourd'hui je suis très
21 et demain j'embauche à 6h avec les
transports parisiens ça me fait pas
grand chose à dormir
vous êtes marié oui je suis marié
comment êtes-vous
que la SNCF à Saint-Michel-sur-Orge
700 francs par mois
en F3 comment vous en tirez-vous avec un
salaire qui dépasse à peine 800 francs
et un loyer de 500 francs
qu'une sortie on n'a pas à la maison on
achète le minimum ce dont on a besoin
c'est tout
pour rien faire d'autre pour s'en sortir
est-ce que vous avez l'espoir d'une
amélioration de carrière quel est votre
avenir à la SNCF oh je pense aucune ou
alors monter d'une échelle tous les 10
ans mais ça va vite arriver à la
retraite et on n'aura pas grand chose de
plus que je suis actuellement
là il y a aucun avenir je pense
vous ne passerez pas des examens pour
obtenir une promotion il faut pouvoir
aussi maintenant on avait on pouvait
faire des écoles mais tu as une supprime
les écoles ça nous travaillait seul
alors c'est vraiment difficile à
travailler seul pour passer des examens
avec le travail en plus on a ici
est-ce qu'il y a de vos camarades qui
ont obtenu une promotion en passant des
examens oui certains mais ils sont rares
cela qu'est-ce que vous aviez reçu comme
ça scolaire au départ
et une année de d'études
c'est tout est-ce que vous pouviez
espérer plus avec cette formation
scolaire
bah je pensais pouvoir travailler autre
après mais là absolument impossible ou
pas
quel était votre rêve lorsque vous étiez
au CES
je suis à des études pour devenir
ingénieur
j'étais obligé d'arrêter pour une
situation familiale alors
maintenant c'est vraiment difficile à
s'en sortir ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quel travail faites-vous ici de la
réservation de place et parfois des
billets
[Musique]
les places retours et les billets dans
certaines conditions on n'est pas des
livrets on peut pas délivrer tous les
billets pour l'instant c'est un nouveau
service oui c'est tout récent
l'installation de la réserve du mois
d'octobre pour nous ce test et pour le
site ouest et les autres gares étaient
depuis le mois de mars en quoi consiste
la nouveauté alors
disons qu'on évite aux clients de faire
plusieurs fois la queue d'un divers
guichet ils ont les places aller-retour
ou même guichet oubliés alors c'était
l'avantage pour le client
et comment ça marche avant alors
téléphonait à centrale qui nous donne
les classes
et pour le retour on était obligé de
téléphoner en province c'est pour ça
qu'on demandait le 48 heures ou 24
heures de dîner
combien y avait-il de d'employés qui
travaillaient autrefois dans le service
de la réservation téléphonique
au service location et de y avoir dans
les 35 employés plus un autre bureau qui
était en contact avec les agences ou les
agences de voyages demandaient leur
place
vous devez y avoir aussi une quarantaine
perso
et ici à la réservation électronique
combien il y en a t-il le trentaine
quand même
que sont devenus les autres
problèmes beaucoup d'auxiliaires ont été
licenciés d'autres ont écarts classés
au craignant c'est à dire au passage
vérification des billets
avec des horaires impossibles ou comment
s'installer du matin ou finissant à une
heure le soir pour certaines personnes
la plupart des femmes c'est un problème
et vous qu'est-ce que vous faisiez avant
d'être ici j'étais également au lycée en
travaillant faisait renseignements et
locations tout à la fois parce que
maintenant on ne fait que la location
exclusivement est-ce que vous avez reçu
une formation professionnelle pour venir
ici travailler sur un ordinateur la
plupart d'entre nous on a fait 15 jours
de stage
de théorie est un petit peu de pratique
et puis la pratique on l'a prise
nous-même sur le terminal on pourrait me
dire
est-ce que vous avez l'impression de
posséder une qualification
professionnelle maintenant
elle peut vous servir ailleurs est-ce
que vous pouvez travailler sur
ordinateur dans une autre entreprise si
vous arrivez à un problème ici
un agence de voyage peut-être je pense
oui
dans une autre entreprise pas forcément
parce que c'est si on peut à part notre
système
les agences de voyage ont aussi des
terminaux d'ordinateur
pas toutes les grandes agences oui pas
les petites agences téléphoniques en
centrale d'ordinateurs
est-ce que le billet coûte plus cher en
agence qu'avec SNCF non c'est la même
chose mais là SNCF donc c'est pour ça
l'agence pour publier vendu
alors le service des agences coûtent de
l'argent à la SNCF oui
le salaire le plus bas il doit être un
virement de 1300 francs et une personne
qui a même 20 ans de carrière n'a pas
n'arrive pas au 2000 francs par mois
des perspectives de promotion maintenant
pas du tout du tout
[Musique]
je suis l'évêque
en gare de Paris Lyon à 13h40 d'où
veniez-vous je viens de Dijon ville
vous avez commencé votre journée à
quelle heure j'ai commencé ma journée
c'était 11h523 est-ce que vous avez fini
votre journée maintenant ah mais non
j'ai encore pas terminé
lorsque j'aurai remisé la machine il
faut que j'aille au dépôt de
Villeneuve-Saint-Georges chercher notre
train pour finir vers les 17 heures je
crois
vous avez des journées de quelle durée
alors
[Rires]
quel endroit
moi j'habite en banlieue à
Maisons-Alfort
[Musique]
de la maison
et quand vous ne couchez pas chez vous
ou couchez vous en couche dans les
foyers qui sont qui nous sont réservés à
cet effet et souvent ces foyers ils sont
à proximité mal placé à la proximité des
voies ferrées ou de route des trucs
comme ça
alors le repos n'est pas toujours
pris dans des conditions valables
vous êtes seuls à bord est-ce que c'est
une situation normale pour un conducteur
de machines
un deuxième avion et puis de plus en
plus elle a tendance à être supprimé
il est remplacé par la
par la VH si vous voulez c'est une
sécurité supplémentaire mais c'est tout
il est remplacé par quoi dites-vous la
veille aux automatiques ça consiste en
quoi ben c'est un dispositif il a pour
but de se mettre en action c'est à dire
de couper les attractions
électriques et mettre le freinage en
urgence lors de la défaillance du
conducteur par exemple
alors comment le manipulez-vous il faut
le maintenir pendant une minute si au
bout d'une minute vous ne réagissez pas
vous avez une sonnerie qui retentit à ce
moment là il faut intervenir le le Real
mais ce qu'on appelle sinon la sonnerie
continue puis le train froid ne s'arrête
vous devez le réarmer tous les combien
de temps il faut la ramener à peu près
toutes les minutes environ toutes les
minutes faut faire un mouvement et ceci
sans arrêt de Dijon à Paris sur le
parcours
est-ce que c'est un système qui est un
bon système
c'est une sécurité supplémentaire
parce que bien souvent en ligne ou pour
les arrêts ou pour les incidents
éventuels deuxième agent il est là il
vous aide lui tandis que je peux pas
compter dessus
[Musique]
notre politique d'effectif a été sévère
toutes ces dernières années elle est
nécessité par le maintien de la
compétitivité du chemin de fer face à
des concurrents dans la productivité
s'améliore rapidement et constamment
monsieur l'évêque cela fait longtemps
que vous travaillez à la SNCF je suis
rentré à la SNCF
au moins au mois de juin 1956
ça fait 19 ans
ça a beaucoup changé pendant ces 19
années oui on a eu des améliorations ça
a changé c'est sûr et encore beaucoup de
problèmes à résoudre ça viendra
peut-être
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces années passées
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est votre dernier jour à la SNCF comme
cheminots depuis combien de temps est-il
joué à la SNCF 32 ans et 3 mois et 31
ans et 6 mois comment avez-vous débuté
comme ajuster en 1942 du temps de la
43 comme ajuster et vous êtes devenu
conducteur à quelle époque
ah bah c'est à quelle année en 1900 j'ai
commencé sur les machines en 1943 à la
vapeur
ensuite on a continué jusqu'en
1950 alors les trafiquants de du réseau
sud-est j'étais élève en 1951 conducteur
en 1955
[Musique]
ça fait un grand changement pour vous
d'abord de la vapeur
on était toujours à deux et on était
toujours les deux même tandis que
maintenant il y a un godelaroche qui est
avec un parisien où il y a un Lyonnais
tout seul on est tout seul maintenant
souvent on est tout seul
[Musique]
qu'on a quand même gardé un peu cette
époque de la vapeur que les jeunes qui
arrivent bah eux ils sont tout de suite
dans l'attraction moderne alors ils
peuvent pas avoir le même esprit que
nous
[Musique]
il me semble que ça soit le SNCF et puis
les jeunes conducteurs qui viennent ils
subissent l'évolution du modernisme ça y
a rien à faire
quel âge avez-vous 50 ans et 2 mois quel
effet ça fait de prendre sa retraite si
jeune
pour l'instant n'y pense pas trop voyez
on est dans le feu de l'action là mais
avoir une vie de famille déjà là
je crois que ça va compter beaucoup pour
nous de retrouver une fille une vie de
famille normale
elle est correcte combien avez-vous
gagné
en arrière sur ces 30 années de rails à
ces 30 années de SNCF qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez
on a fait un bon métier quand même je
crois qu'on a fait un bon métier on leur
gratte pas
[Musique]
recommencer je crois que je recommence
faut que je me lève à 3h30 je prends le
bon lieu de 4h06 pour que je viens ici à
Paris qui amène-nous ici à Conflans pour
que je commence le travail à 5 heures
si un peu dangereux voilà je peux te
lire sinon je veux dangereux si tu veux
pas attention il faut faire la sécurité
quand on dit
ce que nous vous avons vu faire ici
c'est quoi c'est l'embrayage voilà
l'embrayage avec le sabot
ça sert à quoi
pour enrayer les wagons que ça compte
pas parce que c'est ça
votre ils vont dormir le gars qui fait
rien parce qu'après ça se casse des
matériels là dessus
oui on a des appareils spécial qui
régissent le choc
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont fait un sabot
qui
qui wagons que ça se croche pas entre
l'endroit où vous êtes le G c'est
comment
le loger bien dans un foyer de la SNCF
à feuillé de célibataire oui célibataire
et vous pouvez recevoir chez vous dans
votre chambre quand vous voulez qui vous
voulez ah non
à ne pas livre pour ça
pour la famille oui qui vient me voir
mais pour autre chose je peux pas vous
dire
c'est
tout le monde il comprend ça pour la
question de une fille qui monte avec moi
c'est interdit vous avez envie de
revenir au Maroc un jour où vous voulez
rester en France je pense pas de rester
toute ma vie ici en France parce que
c'est pas mon pays
ça viendra un jour que je retourne chez
moi
définitivement c'est ça
il y a des Français qui font le travail
que vous faites dans rigueur
alors que des Marocains qui font
maintenant leur mariage partout pourquoi
d'après vous
toutes les Français qu'ils ont été avec
nous alors
il y en a qui sont partis à l'armée il y
en a qui sont passés comme brigadier
comme cuillère des postes comme que je
connais des beaucoup des français quand
j'étais arrivé ils sont avec moi au
travail comment ça se passe les
relations entre les Marocains et les
Français ici à la SNCF
de relation je peux pas vous dire des
choses qui juste parce qu'il y en a des
bons il y a des mauvais partout
partout il y en a des bons il y a des
mauvais
français il te parle tu dis bon devant
toi et rigole devant toi il te dit des
choses ouais tu es bien et tout ça mais
après derrière toi c'est sûr il parle
sur toi voilà certains moments c'est
pour ça
c'est un problème c'est difficile d'être
étranger ici c'est difficile c'est
difficile et est-ce qu'il y a des
Marocains qui sont chefs
ça ça arrivera jamais
ça arrivera jamais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il l'avenir du train en France comment
le voyez-vous l'avenir du train en
France on le voit sous un avenir assez
assez brillant puisque la crise de
l'énergie a tout de même permis de
reconnaître le bien-fondé des gens qui
ont défendu le chemin de fer depuis de
nombreuses années malgré les nombreuses
attaques qu'il a pu subir et il est bien
certain qu'on est un moyen énorme de
transport de masse au meilleur compte
pour la nation puisque en principe nous
nous consommons 7 à 8 fois moins
d'énergie que nos concurrents comment se
présente la position du rail face à la
route dans cette concurrence
traditionnelle qui les oppose c'est une
concurrence effectivement traditionnelle
qui datent qui remonte aux années 1920
25 à peu près avec une différence énorme
en ce qui concerne le rail puisque le
rail est en même temps un service public
avec les obligations de service public
et il y a certains qu'il est
facile aux concurrent routier décrémé
les meilleurs trafics et de laisser la
part la plus mauvaise aura
[Musique]
la principale des causes actuelles du
déficit ferroviaire et l'aggravation de
la concurrence routière et les due à une
politique libérale des pouvoirs publics
qui ont multiplié largement les
autorisations de transport
rapports de Monsieur Guibert directeur
général de la SNCF au cadre supérieur
1968 page 4
il y a pas de doute que le
rail est très certainement été
en état d'infériorité pendant un certain
temps ça tient peut-être aussi à
l'importance des investissements qu'on a
accordé aux règles qui n'ont peut-être
pas été suffisant bien que les efforts
qui ont été faits par ma maison par la
SNCF sont des efforts quand même énormes
puisque évidemment il touche la France
en direct et les efforts qui sont faits
actuellement sont en amélioration
d'impression très nette sur ce qu'on a
pu faire jusqu'à maintenant
[Musique]
il faut souligner le retard anormal que
présente les investissements de la SNCF
par rapport à ceux des autres modes de
transport comme par rapport à ceux des
réseaux étrangers conférence de presse
de Monsieur Guibert directeur général de
la SNCF au cadre supérieur de la Société
Nationale 1973 page 11 vous avez
l'impression que l'État a
systématiquement à favoriser la route
pendant des années
écoutez c'est une impression je crois
que vous questionnerez n'importe quelle
cheminot à peu près tous les cheminots
on sera unanime à le reconnaître mais
c'est peut-être c'est peut-être une
impression de cheminots
pourquoi elle aurait dû favorisé
bah la route a été la route est il était
normal de faire des efforts pour la
route compte tenu que tout de même c'est
une c'est quelque chose de très
important dans l'économie du pays on
construit des camions en France on
construit des on construit des voitures
on avait les possibilités d'avoir du
pétrole à la banque maintenant
évidemment le pétrole le pétrole est
plus cher mais bien certains que
l'importance de la route le cheminot là
qu'on prend et il ne gagne pas ce qu'il
là où je suis mis au censurge c'est les
différences de traitement c'est-à-dire
c'est le fait que on permet à la route
des choses comme permis porschemin de
faire
le chemin de fer et le seul mode de
transport à respecter strictement une
réglementation couvrant de nombreux
domaines sécurité conditions de travail
obligation de transporter respect des
tarifs publics comptabilité etc
il est loin d'en être de même pour les
transports
de Monsieur Guibert directeur général de
la SNCF au cadre supérieur de la société
1968 page 5
[Musique]
François Martinez qu'est-ce que c'est le
travail que vous faites là sous la rame
du train
là je suis en train de rechercher les
éventuels avaries de sécurité qui ont pu
survenir en cours de parcours
[Musique]
ça fait partie de mon travail évidemment
que vous faites ce métier est-ce que
vous avez vu les choses beaucoup changer
pendant ces 13 ans
une évolution
du mois du point de vue effectif
nous étions plus de 300 000 lorsque je
suis rentré au chemin de fer nous sommes
à peu près aujourd'hui 270 000 donc vous
faites le compte
en ce qui concerne ma profession
il y a 4 ans que je suis sur les fosses
de Paris lavage nous étions donc
si visiteurs par tram
nous tournons aujourd'hui à 5
théoriquement et très souvent A4
donc il est certain que le travail est
d'autant plus pénible car on nous
demande le même travail le somme nous
avons une vigilance permanente étant
donné que nous assurons la sécurité des
rames
donc à 4 nous sommes pratiquement
obligés de faire le travail de 6 agents
et certains que c'est une dégradation
de notre filière
la politique générale de la SNCF
consiste désormais souvent à confier à
sa tombe de tâches considéré comme non
rentables au secteur privé est-ce que
c'est le cas ce qui concerne la révision
des rames pour l'instant tout ce qui est
petite révision entretien courant c'est
toujours le chemin de fer en ce qui
concerne les causes réparations et les
grosses ce qu'on appelle une RG c'est à
dire une révision générale c'est à 80%
fait par le privé actuellement
sous réserve de conserver dans nos
ateliers un venant de travail minimal
nous avons intérêt à confier la plupart
des opérations moyennes et majeures des
matériels remorqués à l'industrie privée
à Port de Monsieur Guibert directeur
général 1968 page 12
et certains que ça a supprimé pas mal de
très grands ateliers qui faisaient donc
tous ces travaux de très grande
envergure
pas mal de grands ateliers ont été
fermés suite à ces mesures
pour quelles raisons d'après vous la
SNCF pratique-t-elle cette politique je
crois que c'est une politique
la politique actuelle du chemin de fer
est une politique de rentabilité et je
crois qu'ils ont taxé là-dessus
c'est ni plus ni moins une question de
rentabilité pour
[Musique]